[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SUNDAR PICHAI: Welcome.
Welcome to Google I/O.
And welcome to Show Line.
It feels really nice
and different up here.
We've been doing it for
many, many years in Moscone.
And in fact, we've been
doing I/O for 10 years.
But I feel we are at a
pivotal moment in terms
of where we are
going as a company
and felt appropriate
to change the venue.
Doing it here also allows us
to include a lot more of you.
There are over 7,000 of you
joining in person today.
[CHEERING]
And later today,
after the keynote,
you'll be joined by several
Googlers-- product managers,
engineers, and designers.
So hopefully, you'll engage
in many, many conversations
over the three days.
As always, I/O is being live
streamed around the world.
This year, we have the
largest ever audience.
We are live streaming this
to 530 extended events
in over 100 countries
around the world,
including Dublin, which is
a major techhub in Europe,
Istanbul, which is our oldest
Google Developer Group,
and even to Colombo, Sri Lanka,
which is the largest attendance
outside of the US
with 2,000 people.
[APPLAUSE]
Our largest developer
audience on the live stream
is from China today with
over 1 million people
tuning in live from China.
So welcome to those
users as well.
[CHEERING]
We live in very,
very exciting times.
Computing has had an
amazing evolution.
Stepping back, Larry and
Sergey founded Google
17 years ago with the
goal of helping users
find the information they need.
At the time, there were only
300 million people online,
most of them around big physical
computers on slow internet
connections.
Fast forward to today, thanks
to the rate at which processors
and sensors have evolved, it
is truly the moment of mobile.
There are over 3 billion
people connected.
And they are using
the internet in ways
we have never seen before.
They live on their phones.
They use it to communicate,
learn new things,
gain knowledge,
entertain themselves.
They tap an icon,
expect a car to show up.
They talk to their
phones and even
expect music to
play in the living
room or, sometimes, groceries
to show up at the front door.
So we are pushing
ourselves really hard,
so that Google is
evolving and staying
a step ahead of our users.
All the queries
you see behind me
are live queries
coming in from mobile.
In fact, today, over
50% of our queries
come from mobile phones.
And the queries in color you
see behind me are voice queries.
In the US, on our mobile app
and Android, 1 in 5 queries,
20% of our queries,
are voice queries.
And that share is growing.
Given how differently
users are engaging with us,
we want to push
ourselves and deliver
them information,
rich information,
in the context of mobile.
This is why, if you come
to Google today and search
for Beyonce, you don't
just get 10 blue links,
you get a rich information
card with music,
you can listen to her
songs, find information
about upcoming show events,
and book it right there.
You can come and
ask us different
queries-- presidential
elections or Champions League,
and we again give you
rich in-depth information.
And we do this across thousands
and thousands of categories
globally at scale.
You can come to Google
looking for news as well.
For example, if you're
interested in Hyperloop,
an exciting
technology, we give you
information with AMP right
there in search results.
And they load instantly, and
you can scroll through them.
Amazing to see how people
engage differently with Google.
It's not just enough
to give them links.
We really need to help them get
things done in the real world.
This is why we are
evolving search
to be much more assistive.
We've been laying the foundation
for this for many, many years
through investments in deep
areas of computer science.
We built the Knowledge Graph.
We, today, have an understanding
of 1 billion entities-- people,
places, and things-- and the
relationships between them
and the real world.
We have dramatically
improved the quality
of our voice recognition.
We recently started training our
datasets with noisy backgrounds
deliberately, so that we can
hear people more accurately.
The quality is improved
recently by 25%.
Image recognition
and computer vision,
we can do things which we never
thought we could do before.
If you're in Google Photos
today and you search for hugs,
we actually pull
all the pictures
of people hugging in
your personal collection.
[APPLAUSE]
We have recently
extended this to videos.
So you can say, show
me my dog videos,
and we actually go
through your videos
and pull out your
favorite videos.
Translation, 10
years ago, we could
translate, machine-translate
in two languages.
Today, we do that for
over 100 languages.
And every single day, we
translate over 140 billion
words for our users.
We even do real time
visual translation.
If you're a Chinese user and
you run into a menu in English,
all you need to do is
to hold up your phone,
and we can translate it
into English for you.
Progress in all
of these areas is
accelerating thanks
to profound advances
in machine learning and AI.
And I believe we are
at a seminal moment.
We, as Google, have
evolved significantly
over the past 10 years.
And we believe we are poised
to take a big leap forward
in the next 10 years.
So leveraging our
state-of-the-art capabilities
in machine learning and AI,
we truly want to take the next
step in being more
assistive for our users.
So today, we are announcing
the Google Assistant.
[APPLAUSE]
So what do we mean when we
say the Google Assistant?
We want to be there for
our users, asking them, hi,
how can I help?
We think of the Assistant
in a very specific way.
We think of it as a
conversational assistant.
You want users to have an
ongoing two-way dialogue
with Google.
We want you to help get things
done in your real world.
And we want to do it for you,
understanding your context,
giving you control of it.
We think of this as
building each user
their own individual Google.
We already have elements of
the Assistant working hard
for our users.
I mentioned earlier that 20%
of queries on our mobile app
and Android in the
US are voice queries.
Every single day,
people say, OK, Google
and ask us questions
that we help them with.
And we have started becoming
truly conversational
because of our strengths in
natural language processing.
For example, you can be in front
of this structure in Chicago
and ask Google,
who designed this?
You don't need to say the
beam or the cloud gate.
Understand your context, and
we answer that the designer
is Anish Kapoor.
Here's another example.
You can ask Google, who
directed "The Revenant"--
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: "The
Revenant" was directed
by Alejandro Gonzalez Inarritu.
SUNDAR PICHAI: And you can
follow that up with a question,
show me his awards.
Notice that I didn't
say the name, which
I'm glad, because I find
that name very, very
hard to pronounce.
[LAUGHTER]
And Google could pick
that conversation up
and return the right to answer.
This has historically
been really
hard to do for computers.
The reason we are
able to do this
is because we have
invested the last decade
in building the world's best
natural language processing
technology.
And our ability to do
conversational understanding
is far ahead of what
other assistants can do.
Especially if you look
at follow-on queries,
our studies show that we
are an order of magnitude
ahead of everyone else.
So today, people are using
Google and asking us questions
in many, many different ways.
So we put together a short video
so that you can take a look.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - LIZZO, "W.E.R.K."]
-OK, Google, show me the
trailer for "Angry Birds."
-Fire!
-How old is the Taj Mahal?
Whoa!
Take me to that.
-Here are some headlines.
-What's Picasso's full name?
-Pablo Diego Jose Francisco de
Paula Juan Nepomuceno Maria--
[MUSIC - LIZZO, "W.E.R.K."]
You're on the fastest route.
-Play "Laughing Owl."
-[LAUGHTER]
-OK, Google, [INAUDIBLE].
-Call Gram.
[PHONE RINGING]
-Hello.
-Show me my graduation photos.
-It's 29 degrees and clear.
-Your order has shipped.
-[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
-Here are your sports.
[CHEERING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SUNDAR PICHAI: As
you can see, users
are already looking to Google
to help them get things done.
But we believe we are
just getting started.
We believe this
is a long journey.
And given it's a
journey, we want
to talk to you a little
bit about the future.
We want to show you the kind
of things we ask [INAUDIBLE]
to be able to do.
Now, let me do that
with an example.
Here's a common situation.
It's Friday night.
I'm sure many of you can
relate to it back home.
And I want to take
my family to a movie.
You know, you normally
pull out your phone,
research movies,
look at the reviews,
find shows nearby, and
try to book a ticket.
We want to be there in
these moments helping you.
So you should be able to ask
Google, what's playing tonight?
And by the way, today,
if you ask that question,
we do return movie results, but
we want to go a step further.
We want to send your
context and maybe suggest
three relevant movies which
you would like nearby.
I should be able to look at
it and maybe tell Google,
we want to bring
the kids this time.
And then if that's the case,
Google should refine the answer
and suggest family friendly
options and maybe even ask me,
would you like four
tickets to any of these?
And if I say, sure,
let's do "Jungle Book,"
it should go ahead
and get the tickets
and have them ready waiting
for me when I need it.
[APPLAUSE]
As you can see, I engage in
a conversation with Google,
and it helped me get
things done in my context.
And by the way, this is just
one version of the conversation.
This could have gone
many, many different ways.
For example, when Google
returned the results,
I could've asked, is
"Jungle Book" any good?
And Google could have
given me the reviews
and maybe even
shown me a trailer.
And by the way, I saw the movie.
It's terrific and hope
you get to see it as well.
Every single conversation
is different.
Every single context
And we are working hard
to do this for billions
of conversations for
billions of users
around the world for everyone.
We think of the
Assistant as an ambient
experience that
extends across devices.
I think computing is poised
to evolve beyond just phones.
It'll be in the context
of a user's daily life.
It'll be on their phones,
devices they wear,
in their cars, and even
in their living rooms.
For example, if you're in one of
the 100 different Android Auto
models and you're
driving and you say,
let's have curry
tonight, we know
the Warriors are on tonight
and Steph Curry is playing,
but do you know all you're
looking for is food.
And we should be
smart, order that food,
and let you know
when it is ready
and maybe even have it
waiting for you at your home.
Talking about your
home, we've already
built many, many
products for your home.
Today, we have sold over 25
million Chromecast devices.
So we've been thinking
hard about how
to bring this vision of Google
Assistant into your home.
Credit to the team at Amazon
for creating a lot of excitement
in this space.
We've been thinking about
our own unique approach,
and we are getting ready
to launch something
later this year.
To give you a preview,
I'm going to invite Mario
from the Chromecast team.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARIO QUEIROZ: Thanks, Sundar.
Today, we want to give
you an early preview
of how we're bringing the
Google Assistant to the home.
Our aspiration is to make the
Assistant useful and enjoyable
in one of the most important
places in your world,
where you spend time
with your family.
When I walk into
my house, I want
to be able to continue to have
access to the Google Assistant.
But I should be able to interact
with it in a hands-free way
simply using my voice without
having to take out my phone.
This is why we're creating
Google Home, a device which
will be available
later this year.
Google Home lets you enjoy
music and entertainment
throughout your entire
house, manage everyday tasks
more easily, and ask Google
what you want to know.
All of this will be done by
speaking with the Assistant.
It will let anyone in the
family, kids or adults,
have a conversation with Google.
Google Home is unmatched in
far-field voice recognition,
since it's powered by more
than 10 years of innovation
in natural language processing.
I can continue the two-way
dialogue with the Assistant
that Sundar mentioned
earlier, whether I'm
standing nearby cooking
dinner or sitting
across the room playing
a game with my daughter.
With Google Home, we set
out to create and design
a beautiful product
that's warm and inviting
and fits naturally in
many areas of the home.
We're designing the top
to blend into your home.
We'll give you the option
to customize the base
with different
colors and finishes,
including metal and fabric,
to reflect your home style,
whether it be in the
living room, the kitchen,
or the bedroom.
We're putting a lot
of craftsmanship
into the hardware design,
including the LED's placement
and choreography,
the speaker that's
going to fill the room you're
in with music, the microphone
system, and the clean
face without any buttons.
[APPLAUSE]
This is Google Home.
We think it'll be a
beautiful addition
to any room in your house.
And we're even more
excited about what
it's going to do for you.
First, music and
entertainment are
a big part of what makes being
at home relaxing and fun.
Not long ago, we
introduced Chromecast,
designed to play your
favorite shows, movies,
and YouTube videos on the
biggest screen in your house.
Last year, we added
Chromecast Audio
to bring the music you
love to your best speakers.
Chromecast has been one of
the hottest-selling consumer
electronics products
since the day it launched.
And Google Home will build
on those experiences.
Google Home is a Wi-Fi speaker
that streams music directly
from the cloud, so you get
the highest quality playback.
It will deliver rich
bass and clear highs
all from a beautiful,
compact form factor.
Of course, you can access songs,
playlists, albums, artists,
and podcasts from your
favorite music services
just by asking with your voice.
Or if you prefer, you can send
music from your Android or iOS
device through Google Cast.
And unlike other
home assistants,
Google Cast Support
allows you to control
other speakers in your home
without complicated setup.
So when you want to listen
to Coldplay in the living
room on the living
room speakers,
you can simply say, play "Viva
La Vida" in the living room,
and it'll start playing.
Cast Support also enables
multi-room playback,
so that you can add
one or more Google home
devices to a group of
speakers and really blast
your favorite tunes.
And it lets you control
your video content, too.
Let's say that you want to
watch that episode of Jimmy
Kimmel or the trendy
YouTube video on your TV.
Just tell Google
Home, and the content
that will appear on the biggest,
brightest screen in your house.
Next, Google Home will become
more and more of a control
center for your whole home.
Home is where lots of daily
tasks just need to get done.
Having access to
the Google assistant
makes this a lot easier.
It's like having a
voice-activated remote control
to the real world
whenever you need it.
You can do the basics like
setting alarms and timers,
or managing to-do lists
and shopping list.
We're also designing Google
Home to connect your smart home
seamlessly.
It will support the most
popular home networking systems,
so that you can easily control
your lights, thermostats,
switches, and more, including
our own Nest devices.
Further in the future,
we'll work with developers
to make it possible to
control things beyond the home
like booking a car, ordering
dinner, or sending flowers
to mom, and much, much more,
all with just your voice.
Third, Google Home lets you
ask Google about anything
you want to know.
Of course, you
can get the basics
like the weather or facts that
you might find on Wikipedia.
But what makes Google
Home really shine
is that it has search built in.
It draws on 17
years of innovation
in organizing the
world's information
to answer questions which are
difficult for other assistants
to handle.
You might ask, how much
fat is in an avocado,
or what is Draymond
Green's jersey number,
and then follow up that
last question with,
where did he go to college?
Or try something more complex.
What was the US population
when NASA was established?
You will get immediate, accurate
answers from Google each time.
And the Google
assistant not only
knows a lot about the world,
but it will stand apart
in how it can also
get to know you
over time, with your
permission, of course.
It can help you retrieve
your travel itinerary,
your daily schedule,
your traffic to work,
your package delivery
information, and much more.
And as Google keeps getting
better, so will Google Home.
So that's Google Home-- a
beautiful, smart, voice-enabled
assistant for the whole family.
Enjoy music and entertainment
throughout your entire house,
manage everyday
tasks effortlessly,
and ask Google what
you want to know.
It's early days, but we want
to give you and show you
how we envision the
Google assistant coming
to life at home.
We created a short video
to bring the product
into a family setting
to capture what
it might be like in the future
to have your personal Google
around the house.
Let's roll the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-OK, Google.
Play the morning playlist.
-OK, playing morning playlist.
[MUSIC - PHILLIP PHILLIPS,
"HOME"]
-OK, Google.
Play music in all rooms.
[MUSIC - PHILLIP PHILLIPS,
"HOME"]
-OK, Google.
I'm listening.
-Your flight to Portland
is delayed by 30 minutes.
-Change my dinner reservation
tonight from 7:30 to 8:00.
-Your reservation at Andina
is now confirmed for 8:00 PM.
-Hey, Google.
Text Louise "flight is
delayed, dinner moved to 8:00."
-OK.
Message sent.
-Morning.
-Good morning.
Hey, Google.
Turn the lights on
in Kevin's room.
-I thought you
finished that already.
-Um, I forgot.
OK, Google.
What's "apples" in Spanish?
-Manzanas.
-Hey, Google.
Has my package shipped?
-Yes, it's already shipped.
It'll arrive tomorrow.
-Ooh, is that for me?
-Maybe.
-Interesting.
-OK, Google.
How many stars
are in our galaxy?
-Well, there are about
100 to 400 billion stars
according to space.com.
-Wich star is the closest?
-According to NASA, the nearest
star system is Alpha Centauri.
-Can you show me what
it looks like on the TV?
-OK, Google.
How's the traffic from Pebble
Rock School to the airport?
-Your normal route
has heavy traffic.
There's a faster one that'll
take about 35 minutes.
I've sent it to your phone.
[PHONE CHIMES]
-OK.
Let's go.
-Dad.
-Hey, Google, what's
on the calendar today?
-The first event is Space
Day at Kevin's school.
It starts at 8:00 AM.
-Space Day.
Are you ready, buddy?
-Ready.
-Let's go.
-Come on.
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-OK, Google.
Goodbye.
-Goodbye.
[END PLAYBACK]
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
MARIO QUEIROZ: We're
really, really excited
about what's ahead.
Google Home will be
available later this year.
In the meantime, to stay up
to date with the latest news,
please sign up at
google.com/home.
We wanted to share this
early preview at I/O,
so that we can work with
partners in a more open way
to deliver awesome
experiences at launch.
We'll have a lot
more to share soon
with the developer community
about how to begin to integrate
with the Google assistant.
And with that, let me
ask Sundar back on stage.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUNDAR PICHAI: Thank you, Mario.
Is really exciting to
see the Google assistant
come to life with
Google Home and help
get people things done.
To do this well,
as Mario mentioned,
we really need to work with
developers and third parties,
so that we can provide
these actions for our users.
We already do this a
lot at Google today.
Using Google products,
you can already
book a movie ticket with
Fandango, get a car with Uber,
listen to music on
Spotify, book a restaurant
with OpenTable, maybe
record a ride with Strava,
and many, many more
such use cases.
So we are thinking
about this thoughtfully,
and we're working on
a comprehensive way
by which third-party
developers can
interact with the assistant.
And we'll be sharing a lot
more in the upcoming months.
I talked earlier that
we are working hard
at core use cases on mobile.
One such important
use case is photos.
Last year, thanks to the
advances in computer vision,
we approach photos
with a new perspective.
We announced Google
Photo at Google I/O
last year with the goal to
help users find and organize
their photos and
videos, keep them safe,
and share them effortlessly
with their family and friends
on any device.
We have seen tremendous
adoption with Google Photos.
And just in the past year, we
have seen tremendous adoption.
And today, we are at over 200
million monthly active users.
[APPLAUSE]
Our computer vision
systems have automatically
applied over 2 trillion labels.
This is what allows us, when
you search for "Pomeranian,"
to find the right picture.
And by the way, over 24
billion of those labels
are for selfies.
[LAUGHTER]
We even have Pomeranian selfies.
Google Photo shows
what's possible
when you approach an existing
area from a new perspective.
Another core use case on users'
phones is communications.
It's an exciting area, and
there is a lot of innovation.
But given our advancements
in machine learning,
we wanted to approach
this core use
case with a new perspective.
Erik Kay is going to join to
talk to you more about it.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERIK KAY: Thanks, Sundar.
You know, communications is all
about sharing life's moments--
that great restaurant I
found, the winning shot
in overtime, my
daughter's recital.
Today I could share moments
like these the second
they happen just by pulling out
my phone and sending a message.
Communications is such an
important part of our lives.
And it's an important
focus for Google as well.
What makes me personally
excited about communications
is the potential
for innovation when
you combine the power of mobile
with advancements in machine
learning.
So today we're giving
you a look at what we've
been up to with two new
communication apps that
show what's possible
when we bring
Google technology to this
essential human activity.
The first is a new
messaging app called Allo.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Allo is a smart messaging app.
It learns over time to
make conversations easier,
more expressive,
and more productive
by bringing all the richness
of Google right into your chat.
Allo is based on
your phone number,
so you can easily get in touch
with anyone in your phone book.
This morning, we're
going to walk you
through three areas that
make Allo really special.
First, here are some fun ways
to express yourself and keep
the conversation going.
Then we'll talk
about what it means
to have the Google assistant
built right into your messaging
app.
And finally, we'll tell you how
Allo keeps your conversations
private and secure.
So let's get started.
On the stage with me
to help demo is Amit.
He leads product management.
[APPLAUSE]
And on the screen
behind me, you could
see Amit's in a conversation
with his friend Joy.
So we designed Allo to help
you express yourself and keep
the conversation going.
So of course, there's
a great selection
of stickers which we've sourced
from independent artists
and content producers
from around the world.
But expression is more than
just emojis and stickers.
So we've added
more features that
help you say what you mean.
First, let's look
at Whisper/Shout.
We wanted to give you a way to
add more emotion to your words.
Sometimes you want to get your
point across big and bold.
Other times you want to say
things a bit more softly.
Whisper/Shout lets you
express how you really
feel by making your replies
very big or very small.
Amit, can you show
everyone how that works?
So Amit has typed "yay" and
throws a smiley face in there.
Now watch.
Rather than tapping
the Send button,
he slides it down to Whisper
and slides it up again to Shout.
So down to Whisper
and up again to Shout.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, I think it's
pretty cool, too.
No more yelling in all caps
to get your point across.
It's also fun to add
emotion to your photos.
And Ink lets you get creative
with the photos you send.
Amit's picked a photo of
his adorable baby girl
and wrote "ahoy" on the
little sailor, posted it.
It's that simple.
I use Ink all the time.
It's really fun.
Another way Allo
helps you express
yourself is by letting
you type less, a lot less.
We've taken a page
from the Inbox Playbook
and built smart reply right
into your chat conversations.
[APPLAUSE]
This is especially
powerful in messaging
when you're on the go.
So now you can keep
your conversations
going with just a quick tap.
So you could see when
Joy asks, "dinner later?"
that Amit is offered two smart
reply suggestions-- I'm busy
and I'm in!
OK, I promise I won't
act out any more emojis.
So Allo uses machine learning
to suggest replies on the fly,
anticipating what you
might want to say next.
Now, these aren't
just canned replies.
Allo learns over time and
will suggest responses
based on how you like
to express yourself.
The more you use Allo,
the better the suggestions
will become.
So the suggestions you
see are unique to you.
You could say the things
you want without having
to type a single word.
And since messaging
isn't just about text,
smart replies contain
stickers and emojis, too.
Because as they say, an
emoji's worth 1,000 words.
Do they say that?
No.
Now I want to show you
something really cool.
Allo even offers smart replies
when people send photos to you.
[APPLAUSE]
This works because in addition
to understanding text,
Allo builds on Google's
computer vision capabilities
to understand the content
and the context of images.
In this case, Allo
understood that the picture
was of a dog, that
it was a cute dog,
and that even the
breed of the dog.
In our internal
testing, we found
that Allo was 90%
accurate at determining
whether a dog deserves
the "cute dog" response.
[LAUGHTER]
So let's try
something even harder.
When Joy sends a
photo of pasta, we're
able to identify the
precise details of the image
and create smart
replies mentioning both
the linguine and the clams.
What's really cool here
is that we don't just
identify what's in the image--
Smart Reply actually creates
a conversational response,
something like "yummy,"
the kind of thing you
would actually say
in response to a photo of food.
This is only possible
because we've
married our
strengths in computer
vision and natural
language processing.
And if you think
about it, there's
a lot of complex
technology at work
here just to help you say
something as simple and natural
as "I love linguine."
So that's a little
how Allo helps
you express yourself and keep
your conversations going.
The intelligence
behind Smart Reply
also gives you a taste at
how assistive technology can
make your message experience
simpler and more productive.
The Google assistant
built right into Allo
takes it even farther.
So I'm pleased to introduce
one of our leads, Rebecca,
to tell you more about
the assistant in Allo.
[APPLAUSE]
REBECCA MICHAEL: Thanks, Erik.
Since you had earlier,
the Google assistant
is an ongoing
dialogue between you
and Google that helps you get
things done in your world.
It's also designed as an
ambient experience that's there
for you whenever you need it.
And in messaging,
that really means
bringing the Google assistant
right into your conversation
with friends.
So I'm going to show you
how the assistant can help
in Amit and Joy's conversation.
So they're planning
a dinner, and Joy now
said she'd like Italian food.
The assistant
intelligently recognizes
that they could use some tips
for Italian restaurants nearby.
And you can see its
proactive suggestion
at the bottom of
the screen there.
Tapping this brings
up restaurant cards
that everyone in
the chat can see.
These are powered by Google's
Knowledge Graph, which
means that Allo can help
with all kinds of information
in the real world.
So there's some back and
forth about which restaurant
to go to, and it looks like
they're leaning towards Cuchina
at 7 o'clock.
So Amit taps on the restaurant
card to bring up more details.
Looks good.
Serves pasta, which
we know Joy fancied.
So Amit can now go ahead and
make a reservation right there
through OpenTable.
The assistant prompts him to
confirm the number of diners.
And [INAUDIBLE] to eat.
So what we're seeing
here-- [LAUGHS]
What we're seeing here
is completely new.
In the past, Amit would
have had to leave the chat
to do a Google search, return
with some restaurant options,
switch back again to
share the options,
go out again to make the
reservation in OpenTable,
and then come back in
to share the details
with the rest of the group.
In Allo, Amit and Joy could
choose and reserve a restaurant
right there in the chat in
a natural and seamless way.
[APPLAUSE]
So OpenTable will be just
one of the many partners that
will be part of the Google
assistant ecosystem.
And we can't wait
to share more soon
with the developer community
about how to get started.
[APPLAUSE]
Cool.
So we saw some proactive
suggestions from Google there.
You can also call on the Google
assistant directly at any time
just by typing "at Google,"
as Amit's doing now.
And he's going to ask
for funny cat pics.
Really, Amit?
OK.
Cool.
So Google obliges, of course,
with a lovely lineup of cats
from Google Image search.
Wow, that chin.
OK.
So you just saw how the
Google assistant can
be really helpful in groups.
You can also have a
one-on-one chat with Google.
So what we're seeing now
is Amit's contact list.
And Google's appearing
at the top there.
So let's jump in
and have a chat.
Just like with any
other conversation,
this one picks up right
where you left off.
And the assistant will
remember things like your name
and even tell you
how it's feeling.
So let's try something
more interesting.
Amit's a big Real
Madrid fan, and he
wants to know how they got
on in their last match.
So he asks the assistant,
did my team win?
Looks like they did.
They won their-- yeah.
Some Real Madrid fans out there.
[APPLAUSE]
Cool.
So they won their last
match to Saturday.
Let's see when
they're playing next.
That's pretty cool.
They're through to
the Champion League
final at the end of the month.
And we can keep going like
this and find more news
about the team just by tapping
on the suggestions there.
But let's go ahead and
tap on their roster.
There we go.
We have a carousel with
all their top talent.
And should we check out
everyone's favorite?
OK.
There he is-- Mr. Ronaldo.
And let's see some of his
top-- his best tricks.
So Amit only has to
type "best tricks,"
and the assistant
understands the context
in that he means Ronaldo's
best tricks, and responds
with a YouTube video.
[APPLAUSE]
We won't play that video
now, but if we did tap it,
it would play right
there in the chat.
So let's play a game instead.
Amit's asking Google
to play a game.
And OK.
Google's suggesting
the emoji game.
Right.
The way this works is Google
provides a string of emoji,
and you have to
guess the film title.
Are you ready?
Yeah!
OK, let's play.
OK.
So looks like we've got
a crown and some rings.
Any ideas?
"Lord of the Rings"?
Oh, I hear "The Princess
Bride" over there.
Amit, any ideas?
"Lord of the Rings."
Oh, it's too easy.
OK, we could keep going, but
I think you've got the idea.
So that was obviously-- [LAUGHS]
Should we keep going?
No.
Any ideas?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
REBECCA MICHAEL: They're good.
OK.
So this is obviously
a super simple game.
And there's a bunch more
that you can play in Allo.
But we really think that
the best games will come
from the developer community.
[APPLAUSE]
So that was the
assistant in Allo,
allowing you to harness all
of the richness and knowledge
of Google, from search,
YouTubes, maps, photos, as well
as many of our partners to
have fun and get things done.
As you saw, the
interface is inherently
personal and conversational.
And the Smart Suggestion chips
help to keep the conversation
flowing.
But most importantly,
for the first time,
you can use Google in your
chats with your friends.
And with that, I'll
hand it back to Erik.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIK KAY: Thanks,
Rebecca, and thanks, Amit.
I'm really excited about
the possibilities the Google
assistant brings to messaging.
Now let's talk a bit about
privacy and security.
We realize that sometimes
people want to be incognito.
Of course, this applies
to chat as well.
So following in the
footsteps of Chrome,
we've created an
incognito mode for Allo.
While all messages in
Allo are encrypted,
chats in incognito mode
are end-to-end encrypted.
Incognito chats have
discrete notifications,
hiding the sender and
the message contents
from shoulder surfers
and prying eyes.
Incognito also offers
message expiration,
so you're in control of how
long your private messages stick
around.
And similar to when you close
an Incognito window in Chrome,
when you delete an incognito
conversation in Allo,
it's gone forever and no
one could see it again
on your device.
With incognito mode,
Allo gives users
additional controls over
their privacy and security.
And we anticipate adding even
more security features to it
over time.
So that's Allo.
Allo is fast, smart,
and secure, and it
lets you express yourself
in fun, new ways.
And Allo will be the first
home for the Google assistant
as it starts to take shape,
bringing the richness of Google
right into your chats.
Now, Allo is all
about messaging,
but let me talk to you a
minute about video calling.
Just as technology has
helped connect people
through messaging,
video calling has
brought families and friends
together from around the world.
It can be a magical experience.
So why don't we pick up the
phone and do it more often?
Well, maybe the other person
has a different kind of phone.
Maybe the connection
is a little spotty.
And even when it does
work, getting a call
can often feel intrusive,
because you're not quite sure
why the other person's calling.
That's why we
challenged ourselves
to design a video
calling experience that
would feel magical every time.
So I'd like to
introduce you to Duo,
a simple, one-to-one video
calling app for everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
Duo is the video
companion to Allo.
It's fast and performs
well even on slow networks.
It's end-to-end encrypted.
It's based on your
phone number, allowing
you to easily get in touch
with the people you care about.
And it works on both
Android and iOS.
But here's a feature that
makes Allo really special.
We call it Knock Knock.
Knock Knock shows you a live
video stream of the caller
before you've even picked up.
Not only can you see who's
calling, but what they're up to
and why they're calling.
A smile, a beach, a
newborn baby can all
draw you into the
moment, making calls
feel spontaneous and natural.
And once you pick up, Duo
puts you right into the call,
seamlessly transitioning
from the live preview
to the live call.
Knock Knock totally
changes what it's
like to receive a video call.
So let's take a look.
[RINGING]
And almost right on
cue, I'm getting a call
from my daughter Ava.
I use Ava for all my demos.
So as you can see-- and
Elena, apparently, too
is popping in there.
I haven't even picked up
yet, but Ava's right there,
smiling and making funny faces.
I can tell she's
really eager to talk.
So let's answer it.
[CHIME]
AVA: Hi, Dad.
ERIK KAY: Hi, Ava.
Hi, Elena.
ELENA: Hi, Dad!
ERIK KAY: Hi, girls.
AVA: Are you done with
your presentation yet?
ERIK KAY: Almost.
I'll be done soon.
Could you wave to everybody?
AVA: Hi, everybody.
ERIK KAY: All right.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Bye.
I'll talk to you soon.
AVA: Bye, Dad.
ELENA: Bye!
[PHONE HANGS UP]
[LAUGHTER]
ERIK KAY: Oops.
So you just saw how
Knock Knock drew us
into the conversation
with Ava and Elena
before we even picked it up,
and how fast and smooth it was.
Now, Knock Knock only works
when the video is instant.
There can't be a gap
between the phone ringing
and the video appearing.
This is a really hard
technical problem,
but we're uniquely
positioned to tackle it.
Duo was built by the
team that created WebRTC,
the open-source platform that
now powers much of today's
mobile video communication.
And we know this technology
like no one else.
We used a new
protocol called Quick
that allows Duo to establish
an encrypted connection
in a single round trip.
We obsessed over every last
detail of video transmission,
hand-tuning and optimizing
codecs, bandwidth probing,
encryption, and more.
The result is the unique
feel of Knock Knock.
You're right there
in an instant.
So the other thing that
really sets Duo apart
is how reliable it
makes video calling.
Duo works wherever
you are, whether it's
New York or New Delhi,
Buenos Aires or Butte,
at home or on the road.
Duo proactively monitors
network quality multiple times
per second, allowing
to degrade gracefully
when bandwidth is limited
and to seamlessly switch
between Wi-Fi and cellular.
And of course, this all
happens automatically
behind the scenes, so you
don't have to worry about it.
All this technology combines
with a smooth interface
that fades away,
allowing you to focus
on each other in beautiful
HD video and audio.
This is what makes
Duo a video calling
experience that feels unlike
anything you've used before.
Now I'd like to show you a short
video that shows how Duo brings
magic back to video calling.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-(WHISPERING)
Let's go, let's go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[RINGING]
-Happy birthday!
-[LAUGHS]
-Mm.
[CHUCKLES]
-(WHISPERING) Do you
want to meet baby Alex?
-No way!
-That's too cute.
-[GIGGLES]
-Where are you?
-[LAUGHS] Hold on, guys.
I gotta get this.
[LAUGHTER]
[SHRIEK]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
ERIK KAY: You can really see
how fun and spontaneous video
calls become with Duo.
We're incredibly excited
to be connecting people
all over the world with
these two new apps--
Allo, a smart messaging app
with expression and the power
of Google assistant;
and Duo, a simple video
app with the spontaneity
of Knock Knock.
Both Allo and Duo will
be available this summer
on Android and iOS.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, to talk to you
a bit about Android,
I'd like to invite to the
stage our resident rock
star, Dave Burke.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE BURKE: Thanks, Eric.
Hey, I'm Dave.
It's amazing to be
here at Google I/O 2016
at the Shoreline Amphitheater.
What a great venue.
I think this is
going to be the very
closest I get to my
childhood dream of being
a rock star on the stage.
There's something
wrong about nerds
being allowed on a rock star
stage like this, but anyway.
So far we've talked
about the scale of mobile
and how we're thinking about
evolving our products to be
smarter and more
assistive through machine
learning and AI.
And a key driver of
this scale is Android.
As you've heard, this year
marks the 10th anniversary
of our first
developer conference.
It's also been 10 years since
we started working on Android.
So how are we doing?
Well, Android is the most
popular OS in the world.
More than 600
Android smartphones
have launched in the last year
alone-- everything from Disney
princess phones to metal
unibody devices tricked out
in titanium.
There's a phone for everyone.
And as Android
continues to expand
into new screens
like on the wrist
and in the car on TVs
and connected devices,
there's increased opportunity
for developers to reach users,
whether they're at
home or on the go.
Android wear-- there
are now 12 partner
brands with iconic watch makers
like Tag Heuer and designers
like Michael Kors.
Android TV-- there are now
millions of new Android TV
devices growing rapidly
with media content and games
from the biggest
names in the industry.
Android auto-- more
than 100 car models
and stereos have launched
with another 100 on their way
by the end of the year.
And of course, Google Play.
There were $65 billion installs
in the last year alone.
And I'm just in constant
awe of all the amazing apps
and services that you're
creating that's fueling this.
[APPLAUSE]
So let's talk about what's
new in the platform.
With the N release, we
wanted to achieve a new level
of product excellence.
So we set about
redesigning and rewriting
many fundamental aspects
of how the system works.
Now, a lot of the features
in N were inspired by users--
how they use their phones,
what they've told us,
and how we think we can make
their day to day experience
better and more useful.
This year, we decided to do
something a little different
by releasing early developer
previews of the N release
before Google I/O.
We want to share our
work in progress with you
as we build it so we have
more time for your feedback.
Also, getting the
platform out earlier
means there's more time for app
developers and device makers
to be ready for
the release later.
I have no idea why, but this
year, the N dessert name
is proving trickier
than all of the others.
So for the first time ever,
we're going to be inviting
the world to submit their
ideas to www.android.com/n.
We're looking forward to
input, but please don't
call it "Namey McNameface."
I should add that we
will reserve the right
to pick the winner.
In the meantime, let's jump
straight in and talk about some
of the biggest changes in N
around performance, security,
and productivity.
Let's start with performance.
We've improved performance
in N in key areas-- graphics
and run time.
In recent Android releases, we
extended the OpenGL standard
to bring advanced graphics
capabilities, usually found
on the desktop and game
consoles, to mobile.
With N, we're making
our biggest leap forward
with the introduction of Vulkan.
Vulkan is a modern 3D
graphics API designed
to give game developers
direct control of the GPU
to produce incredible graphics
and compute performance.
We made a concerted
effort to work
with the industry on Vulkan
so you can use the same APIs
and graphics assets and shaders
on the desktop as well as
mobile.
Because Vulkan has a lower
CPU overhead than OpenGL,
game developers
are able to squeeze
in more effects per frame while
still maintaining a high frame
rate.
Let's take a look at
a Nexus 6P running
a new version of the "Need for
Speed" game by Electronic Arts.
And there are a bunch of
really nice improvements
in this version,
thanks to Vulkan.
You'll notice the beautiful
graphics and reflections
and materials on the car, thanks
to physically based rendering.
Also check out the
realistic motion
blur effect which is
computed for every object
at the side of the road.
And there's a really nice water
surface effect on the road.
And the shaders for these are
pre-compiled ahead of time
and can now run anywhere.
So that's graphics performance.
We've also spent a lot of
effort working on improving
the Android runtime.
First, we've made major
optimizations to our compiler.
The compiler in N performs
anything from 30% to 600%
faster on major CPU
benchmarks like drystone.
Second we've added a new
just in time or JIT compiler.
And JIT compilation means that
app installs are much faster--
75% faster in N. So now
users can get up and running
in your apps much more quickly.
And also because JIT is more
selective about which methods
it compiles, we're
also able to reduce
the amount of storage unit
for app code by a full 50%.
Now, unlike conventional
JIT systems,
the Android runtime uses
profile-guided optimization
to write compiled code to
flash for the next time you
run the app.
So this improves performance
and reduces battery consumption.
In summary, the new JIT compiler
improves software performance,
makes installs faster, and
reduces the amount of storage
you need for apps
on your device.
Let's talk about another
big area of focus for us--
security.
We designed Android
from the beginning
with a multi-layered, defense
in depth security architecture.
And Android employs the
latest cutting-edge security
technologies, things
like SE Linux,
verified boot integrity,
and full disk encryption.
With N, we're continuing
to strengthen our defenses
in three key ways.
First, N introduces
file-based encryption.
By encrypting at the file level
instead of the block level,
we're able to better
isolate and protect
individual users of the system.
Second, we learned the
importance last year
of hardening the security
of the media framework,
especially since
it's accessing files
from anywhere on the internet.
So in N, we've split
out key subsystems
into individual SE Linux
protected processes,
things like codex
and file extractors.
By improving the security
of the media framework,
we improve the security
of the entire device.
Third-- and this
is something that's
really cool-- N automatically
keeps your phone up
to date with the latest
version of the system software
without you having
to do anything.
LIke Chromebooks, new
Android devices built on N
have two system images.
So when an update is
available, your phone
will automatically download
the new system image
in the background.
So the next time you
power up your phone,
it will seamlessly switch
into the new software image.
You're no longer asked
for your password
when the phone powers up,
thanks to file-based encryption
and a new feature
called direct boot.
And that pesky
Android is Upgrading
dialog is finally gone, thanks
to the new JIT compiler.
[APPLAUSE]
I think the best feeling
in the software industry
is actually deleting
code, by the way.
This approach to
software updates
is one of the most loved
features of Chromebooks.
And I'm really excited to
bring it to mobile as well.
So that's some of the ways we're
improving security mechanisms
in the platform.
But let's not forget about
all of the security services
that Google provides to keep
all Android devices safe.
In fact, when you think about
the scale of Android and Google
Play and the number of
devices and apps out there,
we're providing one of the most
comprehensive mobile security
solutions in the world.
Let's take a look
at a few examples.
Google Chrome
protects users when
they're surfing the web through
a system called Safe Browsing.
Safe Browsing warns
users ahead of time
when they're about
to go to a site
that we know contains malware
or is known to be deceptive.
Today, we're protecting over
one billion mobile Chrome users.
Another example of
how we protect users
is through the
Google Play store.
All Android apps undergo
rigorous security testing
before appearing on the store.
We review every app to make
sure it meets our policies.
We also run an app security
improvement program
with developers to
identify potential security
vulnerabilities.
For example, we've worked with
key banking and e-commerce
applications to ensure
they're using HTTPS properly
to protect against man
in the middle attacks.
Google Play itself is
built on a state of the art
cloud-based infrastructure
we called Safety Net.
With Safety Net, Google's expert
systems and machine learning
models analyze billions
of signals every day
to predict bad behavior.
If an app steps out
of line, Google Play
will block or uninstall
the app, no matter
where it was installed from.
And the scale of Safety
Net is extraordinary.
Every day, we test
over a billion devices
and over eight billion
installed apps.
And all of this
happens under the hood
to keep you safe and secure, no
matter what version of Android
you're on.
Let's move on.
A third area of focus for
us is our continued effort
to improve productivity.
And we've taken a close look at
how people multitask on Android
to understand what's
working for them
and where we could improve.
And we've particularly focused
on the recent Apps screen.
And what we learned
from our user research
is that over 99% of
the time, people only
select an app within
the last seven.
So we decided to simplify by
automatically removing apps
in the list that you
haven't used in a while.
This that makes it much
easier to find the app
that you're looking for.
Also, based on popular
demand, we finally
added a Clear All
button at the top.
Yeah, feels good.
But my absolute favorite
feature is something
that we call Quick Switch.
You can now flip to the previous
app you were in just by double
tapping the Recents
button from anywhere.
You can think of it like
a simplified Alt Tab.
And it's amazingly useful
in so many situations.
For example, let's say
I'm in a phone call
and I'm trying to
coordinate an event.
I can flip over to
the calendar app
I was just in by double
tapping the Recents
button at the bottom right.
From there, I can
check my schedule
and then flip back to the dialer
by double tapping the Recents
button again.
It's pretty cool.
Now, many of you also
asked for the ability
to display more than one
app at the same time.
So we've invested
a lot of effort
in redesigning our window
management framework in N.
And we're introducing two
powerful new windowing
modes in this release-- split
screen and picture in picture.
Split screen is designed
for tablets and phones,
and it's really simple to use.
So for example, let's say
I'm watching a video YouTube
to learn how to make
the best nachos.
I can long tap on the Recents
button to enter Multi Window
and from there launch something
like Google Keep, for example.
Now I can update my shopping
list for ingredients
while I'm watching the video.
The second mode,
picture in picture,
is designed for Android TV.
And it's a great way to let
you keep watching something
while you perform another task.
For example, let's say I'm
watching a live TV program
on retro gaming and they're
talking about "Pac-Man."
And I want to see if I can
install and play the game
myself.
I can put the live content into
picture in picture mode to keep
watching it and then go ahead
and perform a voice search
for "Pac-Man."
This will then give me an
option to install the game
from the Play Store, all at
the same time as watching
the content.
It's pretty cool.
Notifications is
another area we've
worked on to improve
productivity in Android.
And it turns out that today,
over half of the notifications
shown on Android originated
from messaging applications.
So we decided to make some
changes to really optimize
for this use case.
We've added a new direct reply
feature, which lets you quickly
reply to a message like so.
You no longer need
to launch the app
to fire off a quick response,
so it's a real time saver.
We've also added a
feature to give you more
control over notifications.
With N, you can long
tap a notification
to change its visibility.
For example, you can block
notifications from a given app
or set them to
show only silently.
So now you're able to
choose which notifications
are important for you.
One other area we've worked on
to improve your productivity
in Android is your ability to
express yourself with emoji.
And Android is the
first mobile platform
to support the new
Unicode 9 emoji standard.
With this edition are
more human-looking
glyphs and support for
skin tone variations.
Unicode 9 also brings
72 new emoji glyphs.
So now, you can let your
friends know, for example,
when you're dancing
like the left shark
while juggling and
eating avocado toast
in order to win first prize
in that selfie contest.
Basically, my typical
Friday night-- not.
But more seriously, we're
really committed to this space.
And we're continuing to
work with Unicode consortium
on the next generation of emoji.
In particular, you may have
seen some of our suggestions
around better representing
women in professional roles.
So thank you for all the
support for apps so far.
All right, let's wrap up.
Android N is the best
version of Android yet.
I have to say that,
but it's actually true.
We made it faster
and more performance,
with the powerful new JIT
compiler and Vulkan 3D
graphics.
We're continuing to
harden our security
and provide the first truly
seamless software update
system for mobile.
And we're making
users more productive,
with better multitasking,
brand-new Multi Windows
support, and improved
notifications.
In fact, there are over
250 major new features
in N, everything from
Java 8 language support,
[INAUDIBLE] to Data Saver,
setting suggestions,
and much, much more.
You can check out the What's
New in Android session
later today to learn even more.
We're still putting the final
touches on the N release,
and we expect to launch
it later this summer.
But if you can't
wait until then,
I'm happy today to
announce that we're
publishing our first
beta quality release
candidate for you to try out
on your main phone or tablet.
Opt in to the new beta program
at www.android.com/beta and run
N on your Nexus 6, 9, 5x, 6P,
Nexus Player, and Pixel C. Now,
there's one more area in N that
we've been working hard on that
we haven't talked about yet.
And to tell you more
about what it is
and how it fits into
our bigger plans,
let me invite up Clay Bavor.
Thank you.
CLAY BAVOR: Thank you, Dave.
I'm Clay Bavor.
And I lead the virtual
reality team at Google.
[APPLAUSE]
And just to get right
to it, virtual reality
is coming to
Android N. So it all
actually started at a Google I/O
two years ago with Cardboard.
And since then, Cardboard
has done some pretty amazing
things.
There are millions of them
out there in the world,
in all shapes and sizes.
We've enabled
thousands of developers
to build their first VR app.
And users have installed over 50
million Cardboard-enabled apps.
We think that's pretty good
for what is, after all, just
a piece of cardboard.
Now, we love Cardboard.
And for us, it represents
so much of what
we think VR should be about.
It should be mobile.
It should be approachable.
It should be for everyone.
But we knew it was just
a start, because there's
a limit to how much you can do,
how immersive an experience you
can create with some Cardboard
and with phones that were
really only meant to be phones.
We wanted to create
something that
has the best attributes
of Cardboard,
but which is also comfortable,
richly interactive, and far
more immersive.
But to create that
kind of immersion,
you have to solve-- to make your
brain say, yep, I'm somewhere
else, you have to solve a
lot of really hard problems
across all parts of
the VR experience.
You have to design
a system that's
capable of rendering at very
high frame rate and resolution.
To make the experience
really comfortable,
you have to minimize
what's called motion
to photon latency.
That's the delay between
when you move your head
and when the picture updates
to reflect that motion.
And you need to solve for how
you interact with things in VR.
And when you nail
those things, it just
feels like you're there.
Well, we've been working
on these problems and more.
And what we've built won't
be available until this fall.
But we'd like to
introduce you to it today.
We call it Daydream.
Daydream is our platform
for high quality
mobile virtual reality.
And in it are all
of the ingredients
you need to create incredible,
immersive VR experiences.
Now, over time, Daydream
will encompass VR devices
in many shapes and sizes.
But today is about how Daydream
will enable high quality
VR on Android smartphones.
And there are three parts
to it-- the smartphones
themselves, including VR
optimizations to Android N,
a reference design for a
headset and a controller,
and apps, both how you get
them, through Google Play,
and the apps themselves.
We've designed and built
each part in concert
with the others, with a
focus on getting the end
to end user
experience just right.
So let's start with smartphones.
Now, the first thing
we did was look
at what it takes to
build a smartphone that's
great at being a
smartphone but also
at being the core
of a VR system.
And with input from
the major silicon
vendors and smartphone
manufacturers,
we've created a set of
phone specifications for VR.
We call phones that meet
these specs Daydream-ready
The specs include things
like high performance sensors
for accurate head tracking,
displays with a fast response
time to minimize blur and
powerful mobile processors.
And if a phone
meets these specs,
it'll be capable of delivering
a great VR experience.
But the smartphone itself--
it's only part of the story.
The operating system,
the software--
it needs to be able to make
use of all these capabilities,
all while keeping latency
to an absolute minimum.
So we've introduced what
we call VR Mode as part
of Android N. We've worked at
all levels of the Android stack
to optimize it for VR.
We've focused in particular on
performance and latency, which
we brought down to
under 20 milliseconds.
By adding things like single
buffer rendering and VR system
UI, so notifications and alerts
come through properly in VR.
And all of this makes for
a really comfortable VR
experience that we think
users are going to love.
Now, it's important--
these improvements are
part of the core of Android
N, so the entire ecosystem
can benefit.
What that means
for developers is,
there are going to be a lot
of Daydream-ready phones.
In fact, Samsung, Alcatel,
Asus, Huawei, HTC, LG, Xiaomi,
and ZTE-- all will
have smartphones
that are compatible with
the Daydream-ready spec,
and several will be
available this fall.
So that's phones, with
Daydream-ready phone specs
and the VR optimizations as
part of Android N. Let's turn
to headsets.
Now, this is obvious, but a
VR headset, it's something
that you wear on your head.
And because it's
something that you wear,
there's so many things you
need to get just right.
It has to have great optics.
Has to be comfortable.
The materials need
to feel good, and it
needs to be really easy
to put on and take off.
We've taken what we've
learned in all of these areas
and we've created
a reference design
for headsets that
will work seamlessly
with Daydream-ready phones.
We're sharing this design with
partners across the ecosystem.
And there'll be
several of them coming
to market with the first
available this fall.
Now, when it comes to VR,
everyone thinks about headsets.
But the controller, how
you interact with VR,
it's just as important.
We wanted to create
a Controller that's
optimized for VR that's
both powerful and intuitive.
So we've been working on
a controller for Daydream.
It looks like this.
And if we actually
zoom in a little bit,
you can see the
controller itself.
It's very simple.
There are a few buttons
and a clickable touchpad,
so you can scroll and swipe.
But hidden inside the
controller is the magic.
We built an orientation
sensor so it knows where it's
pointing, how it's turning.
You can do some pretty
awesome things with it.
Let's have a look.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
As you can see, the
controller is super flexible.
And the developers we've shared
it with absolutely love it.
Now the controller too will be
part of the reference design
that we're sharing
with partners,
with the first
available this fall.
So we've talked
about smartphones
and operating systems,
headsets and controllers.
But ultimately, that's
not what VR is about.
It's about what
you can experience.
So let's turn to apps,
what you can do in VR.
Now first, if
you're a developer,
you know that there's a
lot upstream from someone
using your app or
playing your game.
Users have to find
it in a store,
buy it, install it, launch it.
This will all work
seamlessly in Daydream.
And that's because we've
built Google Play for VR.
Users will be able to browse
and search and buy and install
VR apps in VR.
And once you've
installed an app,
you can keep coming
back to it from what
we call Daydream
Home, which gives you
access to all of your
favorite games and apps.
Let's actually talk
about some of those apps,
the things you can do and
the places you can go.
Our partners, like the "New
York Times" and the "Wall
Street Journal" and CNN
are bringing their VR apps
to Daydream.
So you'll be able to
experience the world's news
like you're actually there.
Hulu, Netflix, HBO, even iMacs
are bringing their libraries
to Daydream.
So you'll be able to
watch shows and movies
in a virtual cinema or
an immersive 3D film
in a virtual IMAX theater.
Here's a shot from just one
of the dozens of IMAX films
that will be available.
And I don't know
about you, but I
am pretty fired up about hanging
out with astronauts in VR.
So something else that's going
to be awesome in Daydream
is games.
We've been working with the
likes of Ubisoft and CCP,
NetEase, and Electronic Arts.
And these amazing
developers are creating
games that take advantage of
all that we've talked about.
And there are some really
neat things in the works.
We've also been working
on some of our own apps.
Google Play Movies is
coming to Daydream,
complete with high
definition, DRM video support.
That means you'll be able
to watch movies and TV
shows from play, but in
a virtual movie theater.
Street View is
coming to Daydream,
so you'll be able to walk
the streets of the world
without having to
fly around the world.
And Google Photos will
support VR photos,
so you can step inside and
relive favorite moments.
And there's one more-- YouTube.
We've rebuilt YouTube
from the ground up for VR.
In it is voice
search, discovery,
your favorite playlists,
again all in VR.
We've added spatial audio,
improved VR video streaming.
So you'll be able to step
inside the world's largest
collection of VR videos and
experience places and concerts
and events like
you're actually there.
And by the way, you'll
also be able to watch
every single standard
video currently on YouTube,
but in a very different way.
And we think people
are going to love it.
So that's Daydream--
our platform
for high quality
mobile virtual reality,
Daydream-ready smartphones
with VR optimizations as part
of Android N, a
comfortable headset,
and a powerful,
intuitive controller,
and some amazing
apps and experiences,
all designed in concert and open
and at the scale of Android.
Now, Daydream arrives this fall.
But you can get started
developing for it today
with the latest Android
developer preview.
And we'll go to that in more
tomorrow here at 9:00 AM.
So that's it for VR and Android.
To tell you about
wearables in Android,
I'd like to turn it
over to David Singleton.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID SINGLETON: Thanks, Clay.
We launched Android Wear
at I/O two years ago.
And since then, we've
partnered with 12 brands
to pair distinctive
styles with the latest
in wearable technology.
And the result is an
impressive collection
of over 100 different,
beautiful designs.
So whether you admire
the heritage of Tag Heuer
or the iconic design
of Michael Kors,
spend your time hiking a
trail, or riding a wave,
you can wear what you want.
And Android Wear works
with Android and iPhones.
Because no matter what phone
you carry in your pocket,
you should always
be able to wear
what you want on your wrist.
And today, I'm sharing a preview
of our biggest platform update
yet-- Android Wear 2.0.
[APPLAUSE]
Over the past two
years, we've learned
a lot about what people want
and don't want from a watch.
We know that the most
important role of your watch
is helping you stay
connected to what
matters, to important,
timely information,
to the people you love,
and to your health, all
from your wrist.
And that's why we're
evolving the platform
to build even better experiences
for the watch face, messaging,
and fitness.
Android Wear already
has thousands of watch
faces you can download.
And now we're making
them even more useful
by letting any watch face
show data from any app.
So now you can mix
and match the styles
you love with the information
that's most useful to you.
Let's take a look.
Jeff [INAUDIBLE]
from the wear team
has the newest LG
watch with LTE.
And here, you can see a
watch face from Zuhanden.
Jeff has customized it
with his calorie content
from Life Sum, stock information
from Robin Hood, and his tasks
from To Do It.
If he wants to see
other tasks for today,
he simply tabs right
there on the watch face
and sees a reminder to call Mom.
And watches are uniquely suited
to connect us to those people
we love.
You'll never miss a call
from your child's school
or a message from
a close friend.
And that's why we're redesigning
key experiences on the watch
to be even more
intuitive and enabling
new ways to respond to messages
designed just for your wrist.
This includes smart
reply, that knows
the context of your message,
best in class handwriting
recognition, and a new keyboard,
all powered by Google's machine
learning.
And here's what it
looks like when Jeff
gets a message from a friend.
He taps to reply, chooses
handwriting input,
and now he uses his
finger to sketch
big letters on the watch.
The text is recognized
automatically
and now she knows,
with one more go,
she knows that he'll
be there at 3 PM.
[APPLAUSE]
Many of you want your watch
to be like a personal coach,
helping you stay aware,
motivated, and connected
to your body.
First, we're improving
the fitness experience
with Google Fit platform's
automatic activity recognition.
Second, your apps can exchange
data using the Google Fit API.
So information like calories
consumed in a nutrition app
can sync with calories
burned in a running app.
And finally, we're
expanding the ways
you can enjoy listening to
music while you work out,
even when you leave
your phone behind.
When you want to
go for a run, you
can just go with the watch
you're already wearing.
No need to strap your phone
in an awkward armband.
And thanks to the
hardware sensors
on your watch and automatic
activity recognition,
apps like Strava will
start tracking your time
and distance when
you start running.
And if you enjoy music
while working out,
you can launch Spotify
right from your watch face.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And the best part
of all of this-- you
don't even need a phone.
In fact, when Jeff was
showing you the demos,
his phone was turned off.
[APPLAUSE]
And everything you
saw here today,
from sending messages
to streaming music,
works on just his watch.
With Android Wear 2.0,
apps can be standalone.
That means the
apps on your watch
can have direct network
access to the cloud
by a Bluetooth, Wi-Fi,
or cellular connection.
And that means a fast and
richer on-watch app experience
for both Android
and iPhone users.
With standalone apps,
watches with cellular support
become even more powerful.
You'll be able to make calls,
get help from from Google.
And use your favorite
apps right on the watch,
no matter where your phone
is or even if it's on or off.
Starting today,
developers can download
a preview of Android Wear 2.0.
And everyone will be able to
enjoy these exciting new watch
experiences in the fall.
It's time for us to re-imagine
what's possible for wearables
together And we can't wait
to see the incredible things
that you all build.
And now, here's one example
from the wider Android developer
community.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Home is more than just
the place you are in.
It's a feeling.
It was very dangerous
if I will stay in Syria.
So many Syrians have had
to leave our country.
We have about 2.5 million
Syrian refugees in Turkey.
Small things that
were easy in Syria
suddenly become hard
in a foreign land.
I asked myself what I
can do for refugees.
I know programming.
[INAUDIBLE] means
[INAUDIBLE] will help Syrians
navigate a new life in Turkey.
For example, I
want to rent a car.
I want to rent a house.
It also helps connect
you with employers,
tells you how to
get your children
into the schools, anything.
I love programming, because
it allows me to do anything.
It seems there is no limit
to what we can accomplish.
Syria will always
be our country.
But it's possible to make this
new place feel like a home.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
JASON TITUS: Hi I'm Jason Titus.
And I lead our developer
product group here at Google.
And as you can see,
software developers
are changing our
world in a big way.
In fact, it's hard to find
an aspect of our lives
that hasn't been touched,
from how we learn,
to how we get around,
to how we meet people.
You are constantly
finding ways to use
new and emerging technologies
to improve our lives.
And despite all of
the innovation that
has already occurred,
the opportunities
ahead are greater still.
But it's really hard
to go from an idea
to building a great product,
to getting in user's hands.
So I'd like to share
some of the things
that we've been doing
over the last year
to make this process
easier on any platform.
Let's start with the web.
The shift to mobile for the
web platform is well under way.
We've recently hit a milestone,
with over a billion people
using Chrome on
mobile every month.
We've been working on
several initiatives
to try and make the web work
better on mobile devices.
I want to talk
about two of them.
First, we've implemented
powerful new web standards
in Chrome that enable
a new class of website
to gain app-like behavior,
like working reliably
on even the worst
networking connection,
or sending notifications
to reengage users.
We call websites that use
these features Progressive Web
Apps, because they get
progressively better, depending
on the capability
of the web browsers.
And they can lead to
dramatically better user
experiences.
Second, we created an
open source project
called Accelerated
Mobile Pages, or AMP,
to make it simple to create
extremely fast mobile websites
using existing web standards.
On average, AMP pages
loaded four times faster
and use 1/10 as much data.
These things load
almost instantly.
So we're making it easier
to develop mobile websites.
But we're also investing
in native development.
We want Android Studio to be
the quickest, most reliable way
to build Android apps.
I'd like to invite Steph
up to tell you more.
STEPHANIE SAAD
CUTHBERTSON: Thanks Jason.
I'm Steph.
I work on the Android team.
Android Studio is
our official IDE.
It's purpose built for Android.
And it was only three years
ago, right here at I/O,
that we showed it
for the first time.
Since then, it has
built a ton of momentum.
92% of the top
125 apps and games
now use Android Studio,
and millions of developers
worldwide.
Our Android
engineering team sees
that almost all the
professional developers
that we connect
with have used it,
and switched over from
our Eclipse tools.
Your feedback has been
awesome, because it's helped
us focus on the right things.
We care a lot about
making it great.
And there's much more to come.
This morning we'll
release our latest,
which is Android
Studios 2.2 Preview,
focusing on speed, smarts,
and Android platform support.
First speed,
already with 2.1, we
made building and running
changes 10 times faster
than it was only six months ago.
Our new Instant Run
feature drove most of this.
Now, when you hit Run, we
deploy changes directly
into the running app.
The emulators are
three times faster.
And push speeds are
even faster than that.
So all of that
means the emulators
are now actually faster than the
physical device that's probably
in your pocket right now.
But we want to keep speeding
you up to launch earlier.
One of the things
that you've told us
is that we could not possibly
make build speeds too fast.
So with 2.2, we're going to
accelerate build speeds again.
Plus we know Instant
Run's a long term bet.
So we'll keep
expanding coverage.
Another thing we want
to do is make it easier
to write tests to help
drive up app quality.
So a test recording, now as
you just tap through your app,
will record, will write all
of your Espresso test code
for you.
It's basically as if--
[APPLAUSE]
It's as if you had
handwritten the code yourself.
And you can run
those tests locally.
Or you can run them with our
IDE integrated Cloud Test Lab,
to make sure your app runs
well on many Android devices.
Now one of the things
the engineering team is
most excited about is
that with 2.2, you're
going to be able to
build layouts faster.
And they'll run faster too.
So let me show you this.
2.2 includes a rewritten,
feature rich Layout Designer
with new constraint layouts.
So what you're
going to see here is
you'll be able to use
the layout window.
It's almost like
a sheet of paper.
So you can position
your widgets.
And once you're
happy, you'll see here
we save you a ton of
time, because we're
going to automatically add all
the constraints for you, doing
a bunch of actually very
cool math under the covers.
You'll see the UI here
is now going to adapt.
So you can try it on
different Android devices.
It'll adapt to
different orientations.
But what you can't see
is behind the scenes,
your app will run faster too.
So many of you here are
professional Android
developers.
And you know building
rich UI usually
requires nested layouts.
And those are hard to
performance tune at times.
With constraint layouts,
there is no nesting required.
So overall, you get the same
rich UI, less work, and better
performance by default.
[APPLAUSE]
Second smarts, we want to help
you write better Android apps.
The 2.2 Preview includes
a new APK analyzer
so you can figure out, hey
what's making my app so big.
This is really useful
for all of you who
are targeting emerging markets.
You've talked to us
a lot about this.
You also asked for
a layout inspector.
So we have a new
layout inspector in 2.2
so you find out what's
inside your Android layouts.
When you run code
analysis, you'll
find a bunch of
new quality checks.
And that's in addition to the
260 that are already there,
all designed to
eliminate common classes
errors that we see on Android.
And we integrated
the latest version
of the wonderful,
IntelliJ IDE 2016.1.
[APPLAUSE]
The third thing I
want to talk about
is Android platform support.
So we developed the IDE
right alongside the platform,
so we can bring
you the very best.
2.2 includes, to name just a
few, support for N's new Jack
compiler, which is
bringing you wonderful
Java 8 features like
lambdas, default methods.
And for all you developers who
are working on graphics rich,
like games and apps, you
know C++ is critical.
And it's because of your request
we've been steadily building
out C++ support.
Now we already have C++
editing and debugging.
But in 2.2, you'll find a major
change based on your feedback.
In addition to
Gradle, for build,
we'll now support
CMake and Indie KBuild.
[APPLAUSE]
And both of those build systems
will work with the debugger.
And then on top of that, we
made C++ debugging better also.
So I would really
appreciate it--
we would really appreciate
it-- if you download and try
all of this today
and give us feedback.
With that, I would love
to pass it back to Jason.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
JASON TITUS: Thank you, Steph.
It's great to see Android
Studio getting so much faster.
And there's one more product
I'd like to talk to you about.
18 months ago, we
acquired Firebase,
a great mobile
back-ended service
for storing your apps data and
syncing it across iOS, Android,
and the web.
Since then, its usage has grown
to over 450,000 developers.
We would really admire its
great developer experience.
And we wanted to figure
out how to bring that
to other areas of
app development.
We've been working closely with
companies big and small, all
over the world,
to explore how we
could make our offering better.
Today we are announcing the
next generation of Firebase.
Firebase is--
[APPLAUSE]
Firebase is now a suite
of integrated products
to help you build your app, grow
your user base, and earn money.
This is the biggest, most
comprehensive developer update
we have ever made.
So at the heart of
the new Firebase
is a mobile analytics tool we've
built from the ground up called
Firebase Analytics.
It's inspired by
much of the work
that we've done in the last 10
years with Google Analytics.
But it's designed specifically
for the unique needs of apps.
It's great for app developers
for a couple of ways.
First, it gives
you rich insights
into what users are
doing inside of your app.
And it also tells
you where they're
coming from, with rich
cross-network attribution,
all of this in a
single dashboard.
Second, we've
created a new feature
called Firebase Audiences,
which integrates all of Firebase
together.
With Firebase Audiences,
you can group users
based on the criteria
that matters to you most,
and then take action with
notifications, experiments,
and even re-engagement
campaigns on AdWords.
And the best part,
Firebase Analytics
works across Android and iOS.
And it is completely
free and unlimited.
[APPLAUSE]
Surrounding analytics are over
a dozen other major features.
I'm going to cover
some highlights.
First there's cloud
messaging and notifications,
which is built on the world's
most popular cloud to device
messaging platform with
over one million apps,
sending over 170 billion
messages every day.
And now that it's
integrated into Firebase,
you can send targeted
notifications to your audiences
without writing any code.
And like Analytics, it is
completely free and unlimited.
[APPLAUSE]
Now app quality is
important to all of us.
If your app crashes,
it's bad for your users.
And it hurts your business.
Within Google, teams like
Chrome build and deploy
across multiple
platforms at scale.
So we've built on
their infrastructure
and created Firebase
Crash Reporting.
You can use it to quickly
identify bugs and issues
and take action to reduce
impact on your users.
Another aspect of building
a high quality app
is being able to tune and
experiment with features.
So we've taken the
same infrastructure
that we use for our own apps and
created Firebase Remote Config,
which lets you create
experiments and test app
configurations at scale.
Finally to help you grow,
we've creating a Dynamic Links.
A dynamic link is
just a regular URL
whose behavior can be
configured depending
upon where it's tapped.
It persists through the
app install process.
So you can drive installs
while still maintaining
a superior user experience.
So in this example with
NPR, with dynamic links,
we were able to take what was
13 taps down to only four.
So as I mentioned, there
are over a dozen features
of the new Firebase.
And while each of them is
interesting on its own,
the power of Firebase is in how
they're integrated together.
Here's a quick example.
First with Crash Reporting,
you can see crashes
as they're happening.
Then in Analytics,
you can look at what
the impact is on your business.
Once you fix the
crash, you can actually
use Notifications
to reach back out
and invite users
back into your app,
or use Remote Config
to offer them a coupon.
And all of this is integrated
into our Google Cloud Platform,
so that if you want to do
deeper, more customized
analysis of your
analytics data, you
could export it to BigQuery,
Google's fully managed,
petabyte scale data warehouse.
So I've only
skimmed the surface.
But we're going to go into
detail later on this afternoon.
And we have over 30
sessions on Firebase
throughout I/O. The new
Firebase is available today--
[APPLAUSE]
--through one easy to install
SDK across Android, iOS,
and the web.
Please give it a try.
We're really interested
to hear what you think.
And we can't wait to
see what you build next.
And with that, here's
Ellie to give you
a preview of a
new Android effort
that we're working on for you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ELLIE POWERS: Thanks, Jason.
Hi everybody.
I'm Ellie from the Android team.
And I'm here with Ficus
Kirkpatrick, our engineering
director.
We hope that Firebase will make
it a lot easier for all of you
to build great apps.
And we're also thinking hard
about how Android app should
evolve and do more.
We'll be showing you a
sneak peak of a new project.
We think it's
going to change how
people experience Android apps.
And we'll be bringing it to
Android users and developers
over the next year.
Developers like all
of you here have
built amazing Android apps.
They unleash the full
power of Android devices,
seamlessly combining the camera,
sensors, smooth animations,
and more.
But you've really
told us that you
want to be able to bring users
into your apps more quickly.
We want to make it easier
for users and developers
to connect.
For users to access a
wider range of apps,
and for developers
to reach more people.
With the web, you could just
click on a link and land
on a web page.
That's one click,
and a few seconds.
What if you could run
any app with one tap?
That's what we're working on.
We're evolving Android
apps to run instantly,
without installation.
We call this Android
Instant Apps.
[APPLAUSE]
We're going to share
a quick preview
of what we've been working on.
And I can't tell
you how much I've
been looking forward to this
moment for a really long time.
So let's say my friend
Michael sends me this link
to Tasty on Buzzfeed Video.
And let's be completely
clear-- let's
be honest with each other-- I
do not have the Buzzfeed video
app installed on my phone.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to tap the URL
and it's going to take me right
into Buzzfeed Videos Android
app, without installing it.
Ficus, go.
What's happening
here is Google Play
is fetching only the pieces of
the app that we need right now.
There.
[APPLAUSE]
We are in the Android app.
And I didn't even
have to install it.
It was pretty fast too, right?
So here you can see there's
a bunch of different videos,
showing to make a whole
bunch of different recipes.
And the videos start
playing automatically.
Remember it's a
real Android app.
And I can just swipe and go to
the next video really quickly.
The app was able to open
so fast, because it's
been split up into modules.
When Ficus tapped
the link, Google Play
downloaded only the code
that was necessary to display
this screen.
And if I want to keep Buzzfeed
Video on my home screen,
it's simple to install
the app right here.
Here's another example.
BNH Photo and Video has
a beautiful Android app.
But I don't have it on
my phone, because I don't
shop for cameras every day.
Now if I'm searching
for something specific,
like a camera bag, I can still
get that same experience.
With one tap, the app opens up
right to the bag I want to buy.
Technically this is a deep
link to the Android activity
BNH wrote to display
this product page.
And that's all Google
Play needed to download.
I can also swipe here and see
more details about the bag.
Now when I add it to my
cart, the animation there--
it was pretty slick.
And at check-out
time, Android Pay
works just like if I
had the app installed.
I don't have to pull out my
credit card or type in my name
and address.
With Android Instant apps,
I'm already signed in.
And I'm ready to pay.
And so it's going to take me
two taps, not two minutes.
[APPLAUSE]
Finally let's see how Android
Instant apps could help me
when I'm out and about.
So I walk up to a parking meter.
And I need to pay.
I'm in a real hurry today.
And I don't have time to
install a parking app.
But what if I could
just tap my phone,
and with NFC, it could bring
up the parking app immediately?
All I have to do is choose
how long I want to park.
I'm already done.
And now Ficus can run off
the stage to his meeting
and even add more parking time
later if he really needs to.
So that's Android Instant apps.
As a user, it's
totally seamless,
from launching the app, to
signing in, to making payments.
Now as a developer, you'll
update your existing app.
It's the same Android
API, the same project,
and the same source code.
And it can take less
than a day of work,
depending on how
your app is built.
You'll modularize your app.
And Google Play will
download only the parts
that are needed on the
fly, as we saw here.
We're really excited
to give developers
more ways to get their apps
into the hands of users.
In addition to discovering
your apps in the Play store
and installing
them, Instant apps
will provide another on ramp.
People can use your
Instant app directly.
And as we showed earlier,
if they want to install it,
that's easy too.
Most importantly, you
will be in control
of the experiences you build.
And when you do you
make the update,
your app will be just one tap
away for over a billion people.
Oh yeah, I almost forgot
to mention one really
important detail.
So this demo that
Ficus did, he actually
did that on a phone
running Kit Kat.
[APPLAUSE]
You should know the Instant
apps is going to be compatible
all the way back to Jelly Bean.
And we really want for all of
you to be able to try this.
And we're really going to
make it available to you,
just as soon as we can.
But it's a big change in
how we think about apps.
We want to get it right.
And so that's going to
take some time for us.
We're working now with a
small set of developers.
And we'll be gradually rolling
out access and actually rolling
out Instant apps to
users later this year.
We are so excited about
all of the opportunities
that this will open up.
And we can't wait to see
what you are going to build,
when your app is
just a tap away.
And with that, I'll
hand it back to Sundar.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUNDAR PICHAI: Thank
you, Jason and Ellie.
Firebase is the most
comprehensive developer
offering we have done to date.
I'm glad it's available
today, and look forward
to hearing your feedback.
We talked a lot today about
machine learning and AI.
We think there's an opportunity
to accelerate computing,
by working on this
with everyone else.
And so we are trying
to do that in two ways.
First, we are opening up core
components of our machine
learning systems.
Last year, we open
sourced TensorFlow,
so that developers can
embed machine learning
and deep neural nets
with a single API.
In 2015, it was the most
forked project on GitHub.
And it is the number one machine
learning project on that side.
Last week, we open sourced
a natural language parser,
which is also built
on top of TensorFlow.
We are doing these
things so that we
can engage the
external community
and work on this
together with everyone.
Second, for developers
and companies out there,
we are also exposing our
machine learning capabilities
through our Google
Cloud platform.
We already have a cloud machine
learning platform under way.
And you get access to computer
vision, speech, language,
and translation APIs.
And we are working on bringing
many more machine learning
APIs, so that you can get access
to the same great capabilities
we have inside at Google.
We believe this will
be one of the biggest
differentiators for the Google
Cloud platform over time.
And by the way, when you use
Google Cloud platform, you
not only get access to the great
software we use internally,
you get access to specialized
hardware we build internally.
And talking about that
from machine learning,
the scale at which we need to
do computing is incredible.
And so we've started building
specialized custom hardware.
We call these Tensor
Processing Units, or TPUs.
TPUs deliver an order of
magnitude higher performance
per watt then all commercially
available GPUs and FPGAs.
And when you use the
Google Cloud platform,
you can take advantage
of TPUs as well.
TPUs are what powered
AlphaGo, Deep Mind's AlphaGo,
in its game against Lee Sedol.
Go is an ancient
Chinese board game.
It has a simple 19 by 19 grid.
But it is one of the
most complex games
humans have ever designed.
It has more possible board
configurations, many more
possible more
configurations, then
there are atoms in the universe.
Beating Go, for
computers, was widely
considered to be the
grand challenge for AI.
And most people thought
it wouldn't happen
for another decade or so.
So we are really
thrilled that AlphaGo
was able to achieve
this milestone recently.
One thing worth calling
out, in the second game,
there was a move 37 by AlphaGo.
It changed the
course of the game,
and is now widely considered one
of the most beautiful Go moves
ever seen in tournament play.
It was not just an intuitive
move but a very creative move.
We normally don't
associate computers
with making creative choices.
And so to us, this represents a
significant achievement in AI.
By the way, Lee Sedol
has won every single game
since he played against AlphaGo.
And he has even replayed
some of the moves he learned
from AlphaGo in that game.
As the state of the
art capabilities
in machine learning
and AI progress,
we see them becoming
very versatile.
And we think it applies
to a wide range of fields.
I want to give you two examples.
First robotics.
At Google, a bunch
of 20% decided
to help robots-- trained
robots to pick up objects.
You can see it behind me.
This is not new.
You usually do it by
writing control system code.
You program the
robots with rules.
But this time, they decide to
use deep learning techniques.
So you create a
continuous feedback cycle
so that the robots can
learn hand eye coordination
by themselves,
using deep learning.
As you can see
they keep doing it.
And they keep learning
it over and over again.
And over time, they get better.
And they even learn natural
and useful behaviors.
So for example, the robot
is nudging the stapler away
to pick up that yellow objects.
We didn't write that rule.
The robot learnt it
automatically using deep
learning.
So it's an amazing example of
what machine learning can do.
[APPLAUSE]
Another example in healthcare,
diabetic retinopathy
is the fastest growing
cost of blindness.
It affects 4.2 million
people in the US,
and many more worldwide.
To detect it, you need
to do a scan of guy
the eye like you see behind me.
And a highly trained
doctor can detect it.
If detected early, the
treatments are effective.
If detected late, it causes
irreversible blindness.
And it's very, very
difficult to have
highly trained doctors available
in many parts of the world.
So we set out to work with
a small team of engineers
and doctors, and again
use deep learning,
and started training
on eye scans.
And over time, our
computer vision systems
have gotten really good at
detecting diabetic retinopathy
early.
This is still early.
And there's a long road ahead.
And we'll work with
the medical community
to get it in the hands of
as many people as possible.
But you can see
the promise again
of using machine learning.
When I hear about
advancements like these,
I'm reminded that we live
in an extraordinary period
for computing.
Weather climate
change, healthcare,
or education, the most
important struggles
already have thousands of
brilliant and dedicated people
working to make progress on
issues that affect everyone.
Now consider what the best
climate change researchers,
doctors, or educators, can
do with the power of machine
learning assisting them.
As you have seen
today, I'm incredibly
excited about the progress
that we are making
with machine learning and AI.
We believe that the real
test is whether humans
can achieve a lot more with the
support of AI assisting them.
Things previously thought to
be impossible may in fact be
possible.
We look forward to building
this future together
with all of you.
Thank you for joining
us at Google I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]